eddy bonjour
oui bonjour et
duclos on est à notre septième vague de
covin à quel point les tests aléatoires
à la frontière ont permis d'anticiper
les dernières vagues ou l'arrivée de
nouveaux variants en clair ce que
j'essaie de voir là avec vous c est ce
qu on a la preuve que ces tests
aléatoires à la frontière sont efficaces
bien deux réponses de la première que
les tests étaient obligatoires pour tous
ceux et pour toutes celles qui
rentraient au pays évidemment il servait
un rô le majeur c'est à dire que tout le
monde savait une fois rentré au pays ce
est louée ou lui avait l'un cauvier donc
permet tel à cette personne de s'isoler
en cas de positivité aux tests
maintenant qu'ils sont aléatoires il est
encore très important parce que
premièrement on les fait en dehors des
aéroports donc pas d'enjeu défend
structures ou de disponibilité de
personnel dans les aéroports tout se
fait en dehors du contexte aéroportuaire
mais tout de même ces tests nous
permettent de suivre l'entrée de varia
aux pays qui quels sont les voyageurs
qui sont affectés par ces variants d'où
il arrive et par conséquent nous
permettent de mieux comprendre la
situation épidémiologique au pays
comment c'est la vie coville 19 continue
d'évoluer rapidement avec de nouveaux
variants du nouveau soul arias et cette
information scientifique sur la
virologie de lakovic 19 est très
importante par exemple quand on parle du
variant au micron ça se transmet
rapidement plus rapidement que
la coved au tout début
à quel point c'est nécessaire de savoir
que ça rentre dans la part la frontière
c'est comme si quand on sait y est déjà
trop tard le variant il est déjà ici
mais c'est une ministre tu laisses est
longue l'objectif n'est pas de bloquer
les gens lorsqu'ils entrent obéit
d'objection c'est d'avoir une méthode
scientifique
relativement peu coûteuse qui comporte
beaucoup très peu de d'ennuis pour les
gens dont une méthode scientifique
approuvée par la santé publique du
gouvernement canadien pour documenter la
nature et l'évolution des variants quels
sont les noyant dire en tant qu'un
quantité de quel provenance ça nous
permet aussi de travailler à l'échelle
lionel avec d'autres pays qui comme nous
font ce genre de travail et en terminant
ça repose sur une technique que tout le
monde connaît maintenant les tests qui
sont des tests très précis et qui nous
donne la nature exacte du virus dont les
gens peuvent être affectés lorsqu'il
google est ce que vous faites le
criblage de tous ces textes pour
vérifier la présence de variants tout à
fait tous les tests sont criblés tous
les tests position évidemment sont
activés les voyageurs mais c'est du coup
vous l'avez entendu lors de ces
dernières semaines dans les nouvelles
ils ont parfois fait un parcours du
combattant pour partir à l'étranger pour
revenir aussi au retour donc quand c'est
pas les passeports ce sont les fils les
annulations de vol les bagages parfois
qui pose problème est-ce que les
avantages que vous pensez avoir avec ces
tests aléatoires donc un meilleur
portrait de la situation comme vous
dites est ce que ça pèse plus lourd que
les inconvénients que vous imposez au
public voyageur qui est parfois des gens
excédés en leur demandant par exemple
d'aller prendre un rendez vous pour
surveiller leurs tests aléatoires
soyons clairs il ya zéro procédure qui
ont lieu dans les aéroports avec la
nouvelle méthode qu'on utilise pour les
tests aléatoires c'est pour ça qu'on a
reporté au 19 juillet prochaine là le
retour de ces tests aléatoires donc il
ya rien absolument rien pas
d'inscription pas de progression de
tests qui se pose qui vont se passer à
lèvres bord tout se fait par des repas
tout temps comme on disait permettant la
santé publique de continuer à avoir des
informations utiles et précise sur le
virus solidaria et sous les gens là qui
peuvent être injectées une fois qu'ils
entrent au pays n'empêche il faut quand
même le faire le test c'est ça que je
vous dis il faut il ya quand même une
étape de plus pour le public voyageur
c'est la vraie 3 4% déjà qui rend du
pays qui vont alors qui de manière
plutôt plutôt simple se faire tester une
fois qu'ils seront rentrés au pays après
le passage aux aéroports pour permettre
aux canadiens ou d'un magasin de
continuer à voir des meilleures
informations possibles sur le varia sur
les narnia et sur la côte est 2 e mais
cette ministre on a la chance de vous
avoir à l'émission
cette question qui a fait les manchettes
au cours des derniers jours les
provinces exige depuis des mois de
s'asseoir avec justin trudeau sur les
transferts en santé est ce que vous êtes
prêts à nous dire à quel moment va se
tenir la rencontre
vous verrez tejari l'immédiatement je
réussis ajouté pour tous ceux qui nous
écoutent que pour continuer de lutter
contre cauvin 19 c'est absolument
essentiel d'avoir ces vaccinations à
jour maintenant sur les relations avec
les provinces et territoires mais trois
choses la première c'est qu'on l'a
démontré au cours des dernières années à
quel point on pouvait travailler
ensemble pour protéger la santé et la
sécurité des canadiens y compris
évidemment des québécois la deuxième
chose c'est que ce modèle collaboratif
continue on continue de travailler
ensemble avec des investissements
records la part du gouvernement canadien
pour veiller aux besoins les plus
urgents du des provinces et des
territoires matière de soins de santé en
plus des 45 milliards du transfert
canadien en santé de 72 milliards
associé alain koffi 19 noms 2 milliards
que j'annoncerai quelques semaines pour
réduire les retards en matière de
chirurgie de traitement et de diagnostic
et dont 2 milliards en santé mentale en
soins à domicile et en soins de longue
durée mais il ya des défis le long terme
auquel se tourner notre population
vieillit et le populisme trudeau le dis
on va être là pour aider des provinces
et territoires dans le respect de leur
compétence pour traiter de ces défis
majeurs qui nous attendent c'est le
ministre je comprends que vous n'êtes
pas prêt encore à nous donner cette date
là je rappelle que vous êtes ministre
fédérale de la santé un gros merci
d'avoir été avec moi